sie sagen
ers sparen so sehr historisch sehr
historisch war der Ausdruck des Kanzlers
war das alles nicht warum nicht warum
reicht das nicht weil es sich also es
ist alles nicht falsch vieles ist geht
in die richtige Richtung ähm aber es
setzt nicht an dem Kern an der Kernfrage
an äh die irreguläre Migration äh zu
also ich sage illegale Migration muss
auf Null sie ist illegal erstmal zu
begrenzen oder zu beenden es sind Themen
drin wie
abschieben besser Recht durchsetzen zu
können möglich zu machen es sind Themen
drin beim Thema Integration in Arbeit
bringen alles richtig es sind äh Themen
drin die sich mit den Finanzfragen
beschäftigen wie man die Kommunen
unterschätz unterstützen kann ist alles
richtig aber die
Kernfrage wie kriegen wir es tatsächlich
hin jeden Tag kommen 1000 Menschen neu
in Deutschland an wir sind ja kein
Einwanderungsland wir sind in
Einreiseland man reist ein und bleibt
und hat ab dem ersten Tag Ansprüche ähm
das funktioniert offenkundig nicht das
überfordert die Städte Gemeinden es hat
auch keine Akzeptanz das ist ja das was
wir jeden Tag sehen und es ist keine
Einwanderung einfach nur es findet statt
und dies muss begrenzt werden diese
Zahlen müssen deutlich runter und ich
bin ich lasse mich gerne eines besseren
belehren einfach durch die Realität wir
werden es ja sehen wenn das hoffentlich
jetzt alles gesetzt wird aber ich bin
ziemlich überzeugt davon dass das was da
vereinbart wurde einfach nicht reicht
genau und die die große Frage und das
ist ehrlich gesagt die einzige Frage die
ich habe wie machen sie es dann es fängt
an zum einen ist die Frage sozusagen was
wir national tun können sind übrigens
ganz konkrete Themen die man auch sofort
tun könnte die vorgeschlagen wurden auch
von unserem Ministerpräsidenten den
Familiennachzug zu beenden für subsidiär
schutzberechtigte da kommen auch jeden
jedes Jahr 10000 über den Weg auf
freiwillige Aufnahmeprogramme zu beenden
würde auch sofort einen Unterschied
machen ähm dann ist das große Thema
natürlich die EU Außengrenze
äh und ich bin sehr sicher wir werden
dahinkommen
einige werden noch lange brauchen
vielleicht bis sie das so sehen ich bin
mittlerweile davon überzeugt dass es
notwendig ist dass wir an der EU
Außengrenze eben nicht mehr einfach nur
es passieren lassen können sondern dort
muss entschieden werden wer warum
weiterkommt und wer eben nicht und wer
nicht weiterkommt kommt dann auch nicht
weiter sie sagten notfalls bis hin zu
physischer Gewalt da gab's ein riesen
Aufschrei wie meinen Sie das na ja
versuchen Sie mal am Frankfurter
Flughafen durch die Passkontrolle zu
rennen man wird sie aufhalten mit
physischer Gewalt das mein ist das ist
physisch ja klar also das ist ja bei
jeder Demonstration die man auflöst bei
klimaklbern die wir von der Straße holen
das Staatsgewalt der Staat setzt recht
durch und wenn der Staat oder in diesem
Fall die Staatengemeinschaft der EU sagt
es gibt recht es gibt Regeln wer unser
Staatsgebiet der Europäischen Union
betritt und wer nicht dann muss doch
diese Staatengemeinschaft auch in der
Lage sein an der Grenze diesen
Unterschied zu machen das heißt für mich
z.B aber auch dass diejenigen die im
Mittelmeer gerettet werden die aus dem
Mittelmeer kommt ankommen zurückgebracht
werden an die nordafrikanische Küste die
bringen sie sofort zurück das ist das
müsen verstehen das ist das ist die Idee
deswegen weil wenn Sie das vier Wochen
konsequent machen zahlt kein Mensch mehr
10 000 € für ein Schleuser um sich auf
diesen gefährlichen Weg zu machen dieses
furchtbares sterben wir sehen ja diese
Bilder es ist ja
herzzerreißend die die die die dass die
Menschen sich auf diesen gefährlichen
Weg machen und das wird ja nur aufhören
wenn klar ist dieser
Weg funktioniert nicht das Heß die Leute
komm an Sie bringen sie sofort zurück
und wie weit geht physische
Gewalt also das wird ja dann immer
gleich versucht irgendwie
nach dem Motto Schießbefehl nein darum
geht's überhaupt nicht die deutsche
Polizei die europäische Polizei wir
haben gerade über Demonstrationen
gesprochen es ist jeden Tag in der Lage
in Deutschland eine Demonstration
aufzulösen ohne dass irgendjemand äh äh
äh äh also was schießen müsste
sondern das heißt am Ende zu sagen Zäune
sind physische Gewalt wir bauen gerade
mit deutschem Steuergeld EU finanziert
Rumänien Bulgarien Griechenland werden
Zäune gebaut um physisch Menschen davon
abzuhalten weiterzugehen und das heißt D
das ist noch keine physische Gewalt das
ist ein Zaun na ja wenn sie dann aber
über diesen Zaun klettern wird man sie
hoffentlich jedenfalls dann festhalten
und wieder auf die andere Seite bringen
und wenn sie nicht auf die andere Seite
wollen wird man sie eben mit
Staatsgewalt darüber bring das
Durchsetzen von abschieben ist übrigens
ja auch nichts anderes wenn jemand nicht
ausreisen will er wir aber gezwungen
auszureisen ist das Durchsetzen von
recht durch die Staatsgewalt und ich
finde das eigentlich was ziemlich
Selbstverständliches und ich finde wir
müssen auch wieder anfangen diese
selbstverständlichen Dinge einfach es
ist hart also es ist ja nicht so dass
das irgendwie schön wäre das das ist
auch nicht so dass man da Freude dran
hat aber trotzdem ist es für mich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit dass Staat recht
durchsetzt und das eben gegebenenfalls
auch mit Zwang durchsetzt das ist das
was Staatsgewalt und Monopol des Staat
hat es ausmacht und sie sagen sie gehen
davon aus dass irgendwann in wie vielen
Jahren auch immer werden die EU
außengrenz dicht sein es hat so wie es
jetzt passiert und seit Jahren passiert
passiert nicht erst jetzt seit vielen
Jahren passiert überfordert ist die
Gesellschaften also wir muss ja mal
anerkennen vor allem die Deutschen aber
auch die Europäer insgesamt aber gerade
auch die deutsche Gesellschaft hat ja
wahnsinnig viel geleistet in den letzten
Jahren also inklusive der Ukrain
3ieinhalb Millionen Menschen neu in 10
Jahren aufzunehmen und das überhaupt
alles zu schaffen so wie wir es
geschafft haben ist immens und ging nur
können die Deutschen auch stolz drauf
sein
aber gleichzeitig sehen wir einfach wir
sind ein Grenzen dessen was ganz
praktisch geht Kita Schule Wohnungsmarkt
wir haben nicht mal die Wohnung aber es
hat auch keine Akzeptanz also das muss
man übrigens auch bei mir nicht ich will
das auch so nicht es hat in einer großen
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung so keine
Akzeptanz und jetzt kann Politik
trotzdem so tun als gäbst diese
Situation nicht und einfach weitermachen
als wä es nichts äh dann ist meine große
Sorge und das war das Zitat was sie
vorhin hatten wenn die demokratische
Mitte diese Frage der irregulären
Migration nicht beendet wird die
irreguläre Migration die demokratische
Mitte beenden heißt es werden radikale
wie wir es in einigen europäischen
Ländern schon sehen äh möglicherweise
dann an die Macht kommen und dann werden
möglicherweise die diese Grenzen noch
ganz anders schließen als wir uns das
nur äh vorstellen wollen ich will das
nicht aber es geht so dramatisch muss
man es fast sagen
äh um die um die
Existenzfrage der repräsentativen der
Demokratie in Europa ob wir es schaffen
irreguläre Migration unter Kontrolle zu
bekommen oder nicht da bin ich
mittlerweile fest von überzeugt Frau
pinzler wie schauen Sie dar drauf ja wir
sind jetzt an dem Punkt wo ich Probleme
mit der mit der Wortwahl von Herrn sparn
habe
aus mehreren Gründen einmal glaube ich
dass die Art und Weise wir diesen
Gipfel den wir am am Montag Nacht bis
Dienstag morgen von außen versucht haben
zu verfolgen dass er
den schlecht redet weil er nicht mit am
Tisch gesessen hat ich glaube bei Herrn
märz ist es eben so denn wir haben ja
CDU Ministerpräsidenten die diesen
Beschluss mitgetragen haben und ich
würde schon sagen der geht deutlich
weiter als das was in vielen anderen
runden vorher beschlossen worden ist
er will mehr Grenzkontrollen er
reduziert die Zuwendungen an an Menschen
die hierherkommen er prüft sogar Zentren
möglicherweise in anderen Ländern wobei
das ja bisher nirgendwo funktioniert
lass in Randa die Briten hab es mit
Ruanda versucht da ist wir haben
Reporter hingeschickt da ist bisher noch
keiner angekommen das funktioniert
offensichtlich so einfach dann eben
nicht und worauf ich hinaus will ist das
dieses suggerieren
dass dass es die einfache Lösung gibt
wir bauen den Zaun Europa und dann sind
wir geschützt vor allen so funktioniert
es nicht selbst die Länder die das
Massiv versucht hab haben schauen sie
sich Polen an wo die die Wortwahl
gegenüber Menschen die gekommen sind
noch viel härter war als das was Herr
span gesagt hat und dann stellte man
fest na ja die haben ein viertel
Millionen illegale oder hab eine viertel
Millionen Visa ausgegeben weil sie die
Leute für die Arbeit brauchen und ich
glaube darüber reden wir nachher auch
noch dass wir ja Menschen hier brauchen
das das ist sozusagen der das Dilemma in
dem wir stecken aber aber bevor wir
bevor wir dazu kommen ich glaube dass
wir dadurch dass wir wenn wir mit der
Sprache nicht fürchterlich
aufpassen wir in einer Situation in der
wir die rechten und linken Ränder haben
denen die Argumentation zuspielen also
wir müssen sehr aufpassen dass wir nicht
nur von Zahlen von Menschenmassen reden
von der Überwältigung sondern dass wir
immer im Kopf haben dass es um Menschen
geht wenn wir beispielsweise von
illegaler Migration reden dann reden wir
und das davon dass wir die abschaffen
wollen dann reden wir auch davon dass
wir das Asylrecht abschaffen wollen weil
jeder Asylant der hierherkmt ist erstmal
ein illegaler Migrant bis er sich bei
der Polizei gemeldet hat so also ich bin
DAF sehr feine Unterschiede weil dieses
Thema sich so unglaublich leicht
verhetzen lässt weil es am Ende immer um
Menschen geht und ich glaubbe das müssen
wir im Kopf haben egal wie wenig wir
wollen dass Menschen kommen es sind kurz
darauf reagieren darf das Erste ist ja
unsere Minister sagen übrigens das
gleiche wie ich gerade gesagt habe her
wüst sagt eher mit der Sprache bisschen
runterdämen nein Herr wöst hat das
gleich gesagt wie Herr rein wie Herr
kretschm wie alle unsere
Ministerpräsidenten das was dort
vereinbart wurde ist alles nicht falsch
tragen Sie alles mit aber es reicht
nicht es ist ja übrigens so dass unsere
Ministerpräsidenten tatsächlich
weitergehende Vorschläge gemacht haben
die mit der SPD und vor allem
wahrscheinlich den Grünen nicht zu
machen waren insofern wisen wenn der
Gesetzentwurf kommt meinetwegen Georgien
Moldawien zu sicheren herkunftstaaten zu
erklären was ja vereinbart worden ist
noch mal dann werden wir ja dafür
stimmen wir wer ich dagegen stimme es
ist ja in der Sache richtig aber das
reicht halt nicht und das ist eine
gemeinsame Einschätzung die wir haben in
der Union das ist jetzt auch egal ob
sozusagen in der Bundestagsfraktion äh
oder oder in den Ländern äh da muss man
anfangen da zu versuchen da irgendwelche
Unterschiede zu finden die Einschätzung
die Ministerpräsidenten haben
beschlossen die H ja sagen können wir
machen das nicht mit nein aber es ist
doch entschuldig ist doch was anderes ob
sie sagen dass die Dinge sind nicht
falsch sind richtig deswegen tragen wir
sie mit aber wir sagen es reicht noch
nicht zwei verschiedene Dinge und ich
glaube intellektuell schafft man das das
auseinander zu halten das ist nicht
falsch deswegen machen wir es aber
gleichzeitig sagen wir wir würden noch
mehr tun nur leider dafür aktuell keine
Mehrheit irgendwie offensichtlich
jedenfalls bei der Bundesregierung nicht
da in der Gesellschaft bin ich sehr
sicher äh GB es diese Mehrheit das
zweite ist asylgrundrecht 16A
Grundgesetz danach werden glaube ich
1000 äh Verfahren im Jahr gemacht 16A
ist so geändert worden aus sicheren
Drittstaaten faktisch ist der gar nicht
die Rechtsgrundlage für das was da
stattfindet äh sondern die
Rechtsgrundlage ist zum Teil Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention das sind subsidiär
schutzberechtigte äh das sind sind ganz
andere Rechtsfragen als das Grundgesetz
deswegen finde ich die Debatte über das
Grund Gesetz ist eine sehr theoretische
es geht eher um europäisches ähäh Recht
und recht auch das durch Gerichte
ausgebildet worden ist äh woer
mittlerweile eine Zurückweisung nicht
mal mehr möglich ist nach urteilen äh
wenn es in Armut äh zurückgeht nach der
Definition machen wir uns in Europa
irgendwann bewegungsunfähig und deswegen
bin ich der festen Überzeugung werden
wir europäisches Recht äh an der Stelle
ändern müssen auch die Auslegung von
internationalen Konventionen und ich bin
sehr sicher eine große Mehrheit der
europäischen Länder weil sie die
gleichen Themen in ihren Gesellschaften
haben wird das wird das auch mitmen
heißt übrigens die Art und Weise wie sie
darüber über dieses Thema reden und unds
ist sehr schwierig machen wird rational
darüber zu sprechen welche Menschen wir
hier denn wollen welchen wir tatsächlich
Schutz geben wollen weil sie verfolgt
werden weil sie z.B homosexuell sind
oder weil sie Frauen sind oder weil sie
wirklich weil die wirklich bedroht sind
welche wollen wir hier weil wir
frachkräfte brauchen also genau diese
Diskussion wird immer schwieriger wenn
Sie darüber reden dass wir mit
physischer Gewalt Leute zurückweisen
müssen das entweder es passiert schon
weil wir Polizisten ja an den Grenzen
haben oder aber sie suggerieren das was
Frau Petri von der AFD 3 Jahre früher
gesagt hat die hat den Schießbefehl den
sie auch in den Mund genommen haben den
habe ich deswegen in den Mund genommen
weil ja immer alle das sofort
assoziieren und das ist einfach Quatsch
es ist Humbug erster Teil zweiter Teil
glaube ich es ist sehr wichtig aber dann
sagen Sie was Selbstverständliches aber
es ist doch sehr wichtig
Selbstverständliches auszusprechen weil
mittlerweileung humb ganz kurz lass uns
bitte ich mein ich meinte das Thema mit
Frau Petri und diesem diese Debatte
Schießbefehl finde ich ist können wir
anders nen will auch gar nicht über
Petri sprechen aber lass uns bitte
ehrlich sein wenn wir sagen das Schotten
wie ab sie sagen wir wollen das Sie
brauchen eine Pause und ich kann das
nachvollziehen wir haben hier häufig
Landräte Landrätinnen sitzen die sagen
geht so nicht weiter und Sie sagen wir
brauchen erstmal Einwanderung Null nee
das habe ich nicht gesagt schon wieder
genaue wortwah ich habe gesagt illegale
migraull undot trotzdem jetzt immer
unterstellt irreguläre sie sagen no
nicht mal illegale s sagen irreguläre
jeder ist ein irregulärer ne ne ne jetzt
mssen wir wirklich
unterscheiden Einwanderung haben sie
doch gerade selber gesagt jetzt lassen
mich Einwanderung Einwanderung heißt
Einwanderung klassisch Einwanderungsland
heißt wir suchen aus wer nach welchen
Kriterien mit welchen Qualifikationen
kommt das was sie ja auch beruflich mit
mit unterstützen ist das völlig anderes
als irregulär re ungesteuerte Einreise
das zweite ist Flüchtlinge unterstützen
in Kriegsgebieten kann man auch anders
als durch das wie ich finde sehr wenig
humanitäre rechtte stärkerin im Moment
geht's nach dem Prinzip wer schafft es
sich irgendwie durchzukämpfen das sind
vor allem junge Männer ich würde sagen
EU Außengrenze so wie ich beschrieben
habe sichern und gleichzeitig und das
unterscheidet dann auch von den
radikalen rechts oder links sehr klar
z.B ein unter ein einer von vielen
Unterschieden äh zu sagen wir nehmen aus
den Kriegsgebieten direkt Kontingente
ausgewählt von UNHCR haben wir vom
flüchtlingshilwerk haben wir früher
übrigens auch schon gemacht werden dann
vor allem Kinder sein Frauen sein die
die wirklich Schutz brauchen aber eben
nicht nur rechtesstärkeren junge Männer
das dritte ist die schutzquote die
Anerkennungsquote ist bei gut 50%. bei
denjenigen die übers Mittelmeer kommen
ist die Anerkennungsquote ich gerade
richtig im Kopf hab keine 20% jedenfalls
nicht viel drüber das heißt der Großteil
derjenigen die diesen wirklich
gefährlichen Weg auf sich nehmen aus
Gründen die ich ja verstehe auf der
Suche nach einem besseren Leben werden
am Ende nicht anerkannt werden nach der
Rechtsgrundlagen des flüchtlingsrechts
aber trotzdem ja nach allem was wir
erleben zu 90% bleiben weil wir gar
nicht in der Lage sind das Recht dann
überhaupt noch durchzusetzen aus den
unter zur absurität dass man ausreist
und wieder einreist wieder Asyl
beantragt und wieder im System ist weil
es wiederum Monate dauert deutsche
bokratie ist da das Stichwort oder
überforderte
Behörden bis dann ein weiteres Mal
entschieden ist also auch das haben wir
dieser Tage gehört bin nur noch mal
einmal ganz klar sagen ich habe
gesprochen von irregulärer Migration sie
sagen wir brauchen davon eine Pause das
heißt für mich null mhm so und dann
sollten wir doch uns ehrlich machen also
erste Frage wie lange ist die Pause die
Sie sich vorstellen ungefähr ich will es
nur verstehen ich würde also ich sag hab
ja gerade schon gesagt illegale
Migration muss beendet werden das heißt
das heißt
ilal wirin nein jetzt gut dass S noch
mal nachfragen dann kann ich ja noch mal
darlegen W verstanden wenn wir ein
Kontingent wenn wir sagen wir nehmen als
Europa wir drehen un im Kreis wir haben
das verstanden nee das ist ein wichtiger
Unterschied ab erlärt abschotten ist ja
niemand mehr reinzulassen ich ziehe das
Wort zurück ich meine damit nicht
abschotten im Sinne von wir lassen
niemand mehr rein auf die notis wir
nehmen Kontingente gerade ausgefürt
bestimmen wir bestimmen der
entscheidende Unterschied ist wir als
Staat als Staatengemeinschaft bestimmen
selbst wer das Staatsgebiet betritt das
ist die normalste Regel der Welt ich
finde die sollten wir wieder durchsetzen
ich sie wollen mich jetzt gerade falsch
verstehen oder verstehen mich gerade
Miss wir reden gerade aneinander vorbei
sie wollen irreguläre Migration beenden
mhm das bedeutet nur darauf will ich
noch mal hinaus um es einfach noch mal
klar zu sagen wenn jemand es also
trotzdem versucht wenn der versucht über
diesen Zaun zu gehen über diese Systeme
die wir uns dann ausdenken wir geh mir
auch sehr viel Geld das weiß die große
Öffentlichkeit so auch nicht auch schon
in Afrika aus ja entlang der großen
fluchtruten das nennen wir dann
Entwicklungshilfe geben aber das Geld
teilweise aus um Überwachungssysteme zu
installieren Kameras und so weiter um zu
verstehen was da passiert und wir kommt
also wir Schotten uns da schon in
gewisser Weise ab tatsächlich versuchen
das zu steuern wenn es jemand denn noch
schafft über diesen Zaun kommt was
machen wir dann mit dem wird
zurückgebracht zu außerhalb der
EU-Grenze oder wenn wenn wir es schaffen
sollten das ist ja dieses Thema mit den
EU Drittstaaten dort Verfahren zu machen
wird in diesen Drittstaat gebracht ich
würde nicht nur die Verfahren in
Drittstaaten machen sondern auch die
Schutzgewährung in Partnerländern
idealerweise dann
dann machen
aber es wird jemand aber das passiert
ich verstehe ein bisschen die Debatte es
passiert jeden Tag ich sag noch einmal
versuchen sie in Frankfurt versuchen
Hamburg W in Hamburg versuchen sie in
Hamburg durch die Passkontrolle zu
rennen wenn sie gerade aus den USA
eingereist sind und sie haben sie machen
das und sie werden zurückgebracht Z
bkontrolle oder wenn sie nicht die
richtigen Papiere haben werden sie
können sie nicht einreisen das normalste
der Welt mir geht nicht darum das zu
kritisieren ich will nur dass wir uns
alle und irgendwie auch als Gesellschaft
darüber im Klaren sind was es im Zweifel
bedeutet ich habe diese riesigen
absperrungsanlagen auch in in Arizona
z.B gesehen im im Süden der USA ich weiß
was dort passiert das ist hässlich aber
ich verstehe natürlich auch die Position
zu sagen das geht so nicht weiter ich
habe die Landräte hier sitzen und ich
ich höre die Klage und ich verstehe dass
es so nicht weitergehen kann aber wir
müssen als Gesellschaft einmal klar
Zehen und auch verhandeln was das in
letzter Konsequenz wirklich bedeutet we
Menschen lassen sich nicht von Grenzen
aufalten das habe ich zu oft gesehen wir
müs über die Landesgrenzen hinaus gucken
was denn in den Ländern passiert und
dass wir eine gewisse Verantwortung
zumindest für ein Teil der
Migrationsströme haben